the minute I started talking about what
I believed and start and stopped talking
about what I did
things happened immediately so for
example if I would go to a dinner party
where you sit on a plane and somebody
says what do you do and you actually
answer that question if you're lucky to
find 10 of the people who are actually
interested in that you can have a
conversation
um but if you talk about what you
believe
you talk about how you view the world
um people who believe what you believe
were instantly drawn to you and people
who don't believe what you believe don't
care and will walk away and the people
who are instantly drawn to you will say
things like there's someone I need to
introduce you to and so my career went
from fine and it went like this so I'll
just give you one example I first
publicly articulated the concept of the
Golden Circle and starting with why in
January of 2006.
okay
bye
I think it was about May
or June of 2006 I was standing in the
Pentagon presenting to the chief of
staff and Secretary of the of the Air
Force so one of the members of The Joint
Chiefs I'm the same idiot
okay nothing has changed the difference
was the way I got there was I talked
about what I believe they said that
somebody I need you to meet that's how I
got my book deal somebody said to me I
went out to dinner with somebody I talk
about what I believe they said I need to
introduce you to this editor I tell I
have a conversation I tell them what I
believe he says I need you to meet my
publisher I have a 29 minute
conversation with the publisher and
three days later they offered me a book
deal
and
and it's only because I worked very hard
to talk about what I believed you have
to eventually talk about what you do
because people want proof
it's the it's not that I think the
what's unimportant it's that the order's
wrong people talk about what they do
they talk about how they do it they
rarely talk about what they believe I
talk about what I believe how I do it
and then I'll tell you about what I do
so and the order matches the biology of
human decision making which is why it
works